clear the decks clear your calendar
you're going to stick around because
we're going to begin this hour with a
milestone moment for Oprah Winfrey she
is revealing her 100th Book Club
selection only on CBS mornings happened
last week Gail talked with Oprah and the
book's author about the novel by Oprah
did not want this novel to end and about
the overall impact of the book club
it's your 100th book pick who did you
select and why I selected
Hello Beautiful
by Ed Napolitano oh my goodness and I'm
so excited for everybody to read it it's
one of those choices where you feel like
I can't wait for everybody else to have
a chance to get to know these characters
that is how I feel about it too a little
background on hello beautiful it follows
William Waters is his name he marries
into a family of four vibrant sisters
Oprah knows this but Anne I have family
of four sisters I'm the oldest Williams
dark pass and the sister's choice is
jeopardize her loyalty to each other and
Napolitano is the author so we welcome
you both but I'm so excited and for you
and really excited that Oprah's picked a
book she kept telling me how long you're
going to love this book you're going to
love this book so I read it last fall
and when I put it down I just longed for
somebody to talk to about and there was
no one else who'd read it yeah
but he read it so that's why I was so
excited to call you what an incredible
job you've done with it but Ann take us
on the other side of the call what are
you doing when you get a call I was
taking out the garbage from my in my
apartment building and the phone said
Chicago and this boy said hi Ann it's
Oprah Winfrey and I thought oh this is a
robo call this is like what Bill Clinton
calls you and uses your name and then
yeah
fill in the blank yeah yeah please vote
for so and so yes so I just said Oprah
Winfrey Oprah Winfrey I'm up for winning
and then I just stood there holding the
garbage while I talked to you because I
was afraid that if I moved the call
would go away and this experience would
go away because honestly she kept
telling me you're gonna love it and it's
so true I had to stop myself several
times from just turning to the last page
yeah just to see because I was so
anxious about how this was going to end
and I wasn't sure yeah why did you like
it I loved it because it's about sisters
yes and I thought it was about grief and
long and love and how love can make you
whole it was about Joy it felt so much
like the truth to me that I wanted to
not only keep reading but I had to slow
myself down from reading it this is when
you know you're in a good book because
you didn't want it to end because you
because I did not want it to end because
I did not want it to end do sisters
resonate with you do you have sisters my
best friend growing up Leah her her
mother had six sisters and I slept at
Leah's house as much as I slept at my
own and they had different versions of
the same face and they seemed more
themselves when they were all in the
same room together than they did when
they were apart and I was fascinated by
them a lot of people have compared it to
Little Women was this like an homage to
Little Women you loved Little Women
growing up oh yeah yes but I did not set
out to write an homage to Little Women
it was really the characters were
comparing themselves to which Mark's
sister they were and I was like oh my
gosh yeah look at that that makes sense
William has a trauma very early on yeah
and so from the very beginning beginning
I wanted to make sure he was going to be
all right yes and Ann told me in the
green room I wanted to make sure he was
going to be all right too I go but Ann
you decide if he's going to be all right
now I had to find out and you really
drove me through the boat she said she
didn't know so are you letting the
characters lead you yeah you're letting
them tell you yeah to see what happens
to him and how he grows and evolves and
whether it is possible help me
understand that how do the characters
lead you when you're the one writing the
characters and letting them decide what
they're going to be answer that for her
please
and I'm in there with them like I'm in
that world and Napolitano has done such
an incredible job of developing these
characters that in the end I will tell
you I thought about these characters for
days yes and I had a a kind of longing
and a grieving for them for days for
days
yes I would imagine finishing the book
and handing it over so it's not mine
anymore I was I was depressed for like
two months wow because I miss them hello
beautiful the title tell us where it
came from yeah so my Uncle Ed who lives
in Chicago he used to send me postcards
when I was little and they were
addressed to Hello beautiful and I knew
he really didn't know what I looked like
because I didn't see him that often so I
felt like he was talking to like my
inner beauty so it made me feel so warm
and seen in a way with that greeting in
the book it's so nice because the uh the
father in the story whenever he sees one
of his daughters he would say hello
beautiful which I thought was a very
sweet moment between a father and a
daughter but Oprah I look at you this is
your 100th book quick as we said when
you started it we have a clip from your
very first book club pick really I
remember this day okay this is one of my
all-time favorite moments I'm having on
television right now you are witnessing
it mainly because I love books when I
was growing up books were my friends
when I didn't have friends I had books
and one of the greatest Pleasures I have
right now in life is to be reading a
really good book and to know I have a
really really good book after that book
to read and what we want to do is start
a book club here on the Oprah show
because I know a lot of you are in
Reading clubs out there and you have a
book of the month and so forth and I
want to get the whole country reading
again those of you who haven't been
reading I think books are important
wow I know you still think books are
important but did you really think that
a book club would be successful I know
when you guys started we thought well
we'll see we'll see Ben remember Alice
McGee yes we started out as my intern I
said Alice said why don't you we do a
book club on TV and I said Alice how are
we gonna do that on TV because you can't
I said you can't talk about books you
can't talk about novels because people
haven't read them and she said what if
we could get them to read them and
that's how it all started yeah they've
done such an amazing job of amplifying
books and authors voices that's amazing
well authors are my rock stars you are
my rock star so before we go over you
know there's a couple news a day uh
items I want to hit with you Donald
Trump has released a book where he's
published letters that he's received
over the years one of your letters is
front and center I heard about that okay
back in 2000 you wrote him too bad we're
not running for office what a team he I
think he'd written a book and said that
he wanted me to be his running mate if
he decided to yeah if he decided to run
and when I heard that this letter is now
going to be a part of a book I thought
oh wasn't that nice of me to write a
note that's what I thought because I'm
always like oh I should write a note the
person did this or I should write a note
so I'm really happy that I wrote a note
yeah it just shows you have good manners
but you're not thinking you and Donald
Trump would be a team no you weren't
thinking I might have thought it back
then I might have thought it 23 years
ago yes are you thinking that today no
I'm not thinking okay you want to clear
that up okay thank you very much thank
you very much Oprah and congratulations
congratulations thank you both
the book hello beautiful is on sale
right now